Hi, everyone.
I'm Javier Luraschi.
And today I'm super excited to
talk to you about using pins
with JavaScript and Python.
But why?
You're probably
already aware that R
is a pretty great programming
language for data science.
So why should we care?
Well, let me show you something.
There was a survey created
by Stack Overflow that
shows that the top five
programming languages that
are the most popular are
JavaScript, HTML with CSS, SQL,
Python, and Java.
These happen to be the
programming languages that
basically run the
software in the world.
Now R is not there.
It has 5.7% awareness compared to
67.7% awareness of JavaScript.
So the likelihood of you having
to interoperate with JavaScript
or having to collaborate with
someone that loves JavaScript
or Python or SQL is quite high.
So how can we get
R to interoperate
with these programming languages
and for us as R data scientists
to collaborate with others?
And that's what I want
to explore on this talk.
But let me give you
some more context.
Rather than talking
about technologies,
let's talk about
a fictional team
that is working on something.
And this team is composed
by three members.
The first one is
data scientist Darla.
Many of you will feel
familiar with her
because she happens to love
R. R is her main programming
language.
She's very into data science.
And she's very, very
competent with the tools
she knows and loves, like the
tidyverse or tidymodels or even
Base R, or other packages
from the R community.
There's one more character
that we'll introduce,
which is graphics Greg.
Now graphics Greg comes
from a background on design,
and he loves using JavaScript.
There's no way that Greg is
going to learn how to use R.
And that's not necessarily bad.
R is great for data science.
But Greg loves doing
static websites
and helping people
with their design.
So really, the
skills that he needs
are CSS, HTML, and JavaScript.
And he's very
competent with that.
And there's one more person that
perhaps exemplifies the Python
community.
And this would be
machine learning Monica.
Monica likes to do
machine learning
with things like network
analysis and deep learning.
And she happens to love Python.
She might be familiar
with R, but really, she's
really into Python.
And it's really hard to
convince her to do otherwise.
So the problem that
we have at hand
is a pretty common problem
which is we live in a world
where not everyone
speaks the same language.
Not everyone speaks
R. So let's try
to solve this problem from
the perspective of Darla which
is our data scientist
who loves R.
What can Darla do to get
us closer to collaborating
with Greg and Monica?
So a lot of the times what
Darla does on her day to day
is analyzing files.
And she has them
in front of her.
She has different files.
Perhaps, we can call
them data frames.
And she usually tidies them,
analyzes them, shares them
and creates shiny applications
and R Markdown out of them.
And you know, it
would be-- it wouldn't
be really acceptable for Darla
to ask Greg or Monica to have
to learn R or to install R and
RStudio to really collaborate
with her.
So in her mind what
she's thinking is, well,
if I can share the basic
building block, which
is the dataset, right,
that she's working on,
if I could share that
with Greg and Monica,
I have a better chance
of convincing her--
convincing them of
collaborating with me.
So what she's going on her
mind is thinking, well,
how can I share
these data frames
in technologies like GitHub,
or Kaggle, or RStudio Connect
to help Greg and Monica
reuse my datasets
without having to install R?
And you know, there's actually
great news for many of you
that are already familiar with
this particular problem which
is Darla, knowing that she's
a competent data scientist,
knows that there is a package
called pins, which we've been
developing in the R community
for the last year and a half,
and allows her to
do tasks like this,
allows her to retrieve data
and upload data into the cloud.
So what is the pins
package as a quick recap?
Well, first of all,
the pins package
allows you to get
a remote resource
into your local machine.
So say, if you have a remote
URL, you have CSV file,
you can create a local cache
on your machine very easily.
Also once you're connected
to those remote services
like Kaggle, or GitHub,
or RStudio Connect,
you can also search
those services
for datasets that
are interesting to you
all within the pins package.
And last but not
least and especially
important for this
particular problem that we're
trying to solve, is
the pins package
allows you to share datasets
in different cloud providers
like Google, Kaggle,
Azure, and RStudio Connect.
And you can do
that quite easily.
And this is something that
Darla is already familiar with.
She knows that she
can share datasets
with other colleagues that
also use R and the pins package.
Now how does this work?
Well, the pins package
is actually quite simple.
You install it from CRAN.
You load the library.
And then you can
ask it to pin data
set, either an R object
or a remote resource
or a local file, into
your local board, which
is what we're doing in
this particular example.
And then after you Pin
that resource locally,
you can use your favorite
tools to process it.
In this case, we're just
reading a remote JSON file,
saving it locally, and then
using jsonlite to read it.
Now that's the simple use
case of the pins package
to bring things into
your local machine.
But you can also use the pins
package to push things out
of your local machine.
And what Darla could
do here, potentially,
is register a board, which is a
concept from the pins package.
The board that she registers
could be GitHub, DigitalOcean,
Google Cloud, RStudio,
Kaggle, Azure, or AWS S3.
And she can basically push
the dataset from something
as simple of an array of 10
numbers by saying pin 1 to 10,
name equals numbers, and
then board equals say,
Google Cloud, whatever.
And the dataset
that she has locally
can be pushed to be shared
to those particular services.
And if she needs to get it
back at any point in time,
she can just say pin
get, and the dataset
will come back from those
services into her local machine
again.
You can do a little
bit more complex stuff.
You can say-- suppose that
you're collaborating in a image
processing project,
and you have ImageNet
You can retrieve a smaller
version of ImageNet called Tiny
ImageNet by saying, pin
these remote resource locally
into my local machine.
And we'll call it ImageNet.
And then what you can
do is you can also
say, oh, give me back ImageNet.
And now I want to push
it to, perhaps, Kaggle.
Because maybe you
did some cleaning
of the data or some processing.
So all of these are tasks that
the pins package supports,
including finding.
You can just say
pin_find, and it
will find the
different datasets
that are available in
the different boards.
So this is quite great.
And if we think about it
from Darla's point of view,
we're pretty close to the
space that Greg and Monica
are interested.
We've moved our datasets from
our local machine to the Cloud.
But then again, then we have
the question that in this case
Nelson Bighetti is asking, and
he's saying, he's thinking,
wait, this is a pretty great
package for the R community.
Why can't we just do the same
from JavaScript or Python?
Rather than having to be
downloading random JSON files
or CSV files and figuring out
authentication and permissions,
why can't we just have
the same code being
used in Python or JavaScript?
And sure enough, the
whole point of this talk
is for me to introduce you
to a new project, pins.js,
which is a reimplementation
of the pins R
package into JavaScript that
supports Python as well.
This enables you to use
pins from technologies
like web browser with HTML,
or web applications running
Node.js or even Python.
And the way that
we accomplish this
is basically by reimplementing
the functionality available on
R in JavaScript.
And this allows you to
interoperate with R.
So if someone shares
a dataset from R,
you can then quite easily get
the dataset from JavaScript
or Python, which is
quite great, and even
push datasets from
Python and JavaScript
back into cloud
service providers.
So how does this look like?
Well, here we have
some HTML code.
It's quite simple.
It's declaring that
this particular HTML
file needs the pins
library and also is running
within the browser environment.
And then we're basically
just defining some JavaScript
callbacks to use pins.
In this particular case, we
are saying Board Register
to register a local board.
And then we're creating a
dataset, which the dataset is just
the number 42.
And we're saving it
in a local board.
And then we're
retrieving the value,
and then we're printing it
into the web page inside a div,
which is our result.
And we can complicate
this a little bit more.
Rather than just
creating one dataset
we can create multiple
datasets in JavaScript,
say, using a For
Loop from 1 to 10,
we'll push those datasets
into the local board.
And then we can search
them and create perhaps
a page table and JavaScript that
shows us all the different pins
that we have stored, which
you can see on the top right.
And we can even go a
little bit step further.
And if you're really into
state-of-the-art JavaScript
applications, you
can use a library
called Babel which allows you
to transpile modern JavaScript
into compatible JavaScript.
And you can make use of,
perhaps, the new pipe operator
to get the Iris JSON
file using pins and then
pipe it into the function that
basically reads this dataset
from JSON and then creating a
data table with the entire Iris
dataset.
And that's what we
see on the top right.
So again, you're
just using JavaScript
to different degrees,
using pins in the way
that you would expect
to use JavaScript.
And similar for Python, if you
want to use pins from Python,
all you have to do
is run a pip install
with the URL that is hosting
the pins.js Python library.
And then you import a
library with import pins.
And then you create pins
with pins.pin number 42.
And then the board where
you're storing these data into.
You can also do things like
retrieving a pin, obviously,
from either the local
board or a remote board.
And then you can also
find and to figure out
which are the pins that
are available to you, which
in this case is just the
number that we just pinned
and the Iris dataset.
All right.
So this gives us a
pretty broad overview
of how the pins package works.
Well, we want to see it in
action on a real use case.
So let's think about this.
Darla, Greg, and Monica
get together over a lunch.
And they're trying
to figure out which
is the most important character
of the last book in Game
of Thrones.
So they have some
insight that perhaps,
either Daenerys or
maybe Tyrion, are
the most important characters.
But they can't really
figure out exactly which one
is the most important one.
So Darla, being the
competent data scientist
that we know she is,
she just, after lunch,
she gets back to her office
and launches the R instance
and runs the pins
library to find out
if there's any interesting
datasets on the Kaggle service.
And sure enough, she finds that
Kaggle has at least three data
sets.
One containing all the
scripts from the HBO series,
the other one the subtitles,
and the third dataset
contains the actual books from--
with all the dialogues
and content--
from Game of Thrones.
So sure enough, this
looks interesting.
She uses pin_get to get this
particular dataset and finds
out that there's five books,
five files, one for each book.
She loads the first book
using pin_get and the head
of that particular file.
And she finds that
sure enough, the file
starts with a Game of Thrones
book one, A Song of Ice
and Fire.
Great.
She has the data.
So what she can do
next is something
that you're pretty
familiar with.
She can use tools like dplyr
or tidytext or even stringr
with regular expressions.
Whatever skills you
already know and that you
are learning about
during this conference,
basically, Darla makes
use of those skills
to transform the dataset
from raw text
into a tidy table that contains
the proper relationships
between characters.
She finds out, for
instance, that one
of the first interactions
is Addam Marbrand with Jaime
Lannister, and that
with a weight of three.
And maybe the way that
Darla accomplished
this was by parsing
each sentence
and extracting the
characters from each sentence
and figuring out just
how they are connected.
So yeah, sure enough, she
creates a beautiful dataset
which contains most
of the interactions.
And she reports back and
tells Greg and Monica, hey,
I think that on the
fifth book, there
is a lot of relationships
between Jon Snow
and also Tyrion and
other characters.
So check it out.
And what she does is
she shares the dataset
using pins by registering a
board in the S3 AWS service.
And she shares these cleaned up
dataset with Greg and Monica.
And what is great is that
when Greg hears the news,
he's super excited.
Because Greg is not that much
interested into doing data
science, but he's very
interested in creating
intuitive visualizations
that can really help
us understand how data behaves.
So she looks at Darla's
dataset and just runs
to boot his Sublime editor
or Visual Studio Code
or whatever he uses and
loads the pins package
and then retrieves
the dataset from S3.
And as you can see,
he's accomplishing this
with just two lines of code.
He gets the data.
And then he loads it.
And he's good to go.
So then he thinks about
it, and he's like, well,
maybe I can use D3, which
is modern data visualization
library available in JavaScript,
to like create a network
visualization of how
all the relationships
of these characters looks like.
And sure enough,
he uses his skill
to create this particular
graph which looks actually
quite compelling
and interesting.
As you can see on
the graph, this graph
that graphic Greg created,
there's two major components.
There's one component
on the top surrounding
Jon Snow with other
characters like Theon Greyjoy,
and also Stannis
Baratheon. But there's also
another component of
characters surrounding
Daenerys Targaryen, like
Tyrion Lannister and Cersei.
And you know it's interesting
because this is just
a different type of skills
that is super great looking,
intuitive, that
anyone can understand.
Perhaps, it's interactive.
And it really
prompts other people
to understand this data
set with the scripts on--
with the skills from
Greg and Darla combined.
And sure enough, Monica is
also super excited about this.
She looks at the dataset,
and she's like, wow, I
really need to get into this.
But what goes in her
mind is, I really
want to know exactly who's
the most important character?
Is it Jon Snow,
or is it Daenerys?
I want to know with a numeric--
with a numeric value, which is
the most important character.
And sure enough, with pins, she
can now load the pins library
and retrieve this dataset
that Darla carefully created
and load it into
her Python session
and load the characters.
And again with three lines
of code, she's ready to go.
She can do some more analysis.
And taking the dataset from
Darla and the inspiration
from Greg, it really
pops on her head,
and she figures out that maybe
she should use some graph
processing.
So she loads the
Networkx library
which can allow her to do graph
processing of her graph data
sets.
And she basically uses a concept
called degree of centrality,
to which, the way
that she interpreted--
interprets this
concept is if she
can find the degree
of centrality
of this particular graph of
Game of Thrones characters,
that could also imply which
is the most central character
in the roles of the different
books that are available.
And sure enough, after
running her script
and doing some magic, she finds
out that on the first book,
King Stark is the most
important character.
But on the fifth book, the race
between Jon Snow and Daenerys
are pretty close.
Jon Snow seems to
be a bit of more
of a central character
with a score of 0.19,
while Daenerys Targayen
has a score of 0.18.
So again, she find out that
perhaps, objectively, Jon Snow
is the most important
character in the entire season
and the series, or at
least on the last book.
But honestly, more importantly,
what we just realized here
is that we found out
a way for three people
with three different
technologies and three very
different set of skills
to collaborate together
using technologies
that they all love
and common libraries that they
can reuse to better collaborate
and tackle bigger, more
complex data science problems.
So I'm really
excited to see what
you do with this new library.
If you need more information,
please visit pinsjs.github.io.
I want to say that this is a
community library that we've
been developing.
And it definitely needs
the help of the community
to extend support
for more boards
beyond S3, local boards,
and RStudio Connect, boards
like Kaggle and GitHub.
And I also want to
say thanks to people
that have been involved in
this project like Nataliya
Stepanova and Michael Kalygin.
Thank you so much for
listening to this talk.
And I hope that you are ready
to start sharing your datasets.